programming throwdown episode 125 object caching systems take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. Happy New Year. Happy New Year, Patrick. Thank you. Do you have any New Year's either resolutions or I feel like that word is abused, but do you have anything you want to do this year that's special? I mean, I have tons of stuff I want to do, but I don't make them resolutions because I mean, we've seen in the last two years, it's very hard to predict what's going to happen. But no, I'm not a fan of like, start exercising just because the date rolled over. Like, yeah, exactly. Should always be doing it. So is there anything really
particular, like a skill you're trying to build or anything like that? Oh, man, you put me on the spot. I should have made it before. I'm sure I could have thought of something. I'll put myself on the spot. I think, you know, one of the things that I want to do is I want to get back into reading. I feel like, oh, so one thing is that I'm going to probably go back into the office, into an office this month. And so it'll be opportunity for me to get back into reading books, which it was kind of hard to do. I was so used to doing that on my commute. And when I lost the commute, I still read books, but just, you know, not at the same pace. And so I want to I want to kind of use the commute to bring that back. That's actually funny because my book of the show, I won't spoil it, is the first time I actually got a Kindle during Black
Friday sales and put a book on it. And it was the first time I bought a Kindle book, an e kindle book ebook yeah the first time i had read something on a device like that like not a physical book and actually like read it just like an entertainment book not just like flip through or reference something but actually downloaded the book like read the book cover to cover and you know did it during the break off between i guess christmas and new year's so yeah that'd be a good one for me too wait so this happened this year or are're saying this was recently yeah like a week ago or two weeks oh yeah so what's your take on e-ink versus a display so what I will say is so I just bought the cheapest kindle because I didn't know if I would commit to doing this and so it was a bit of an experiment but I'll say is has a light on it that's a game changer
because you can sort of like i would wake up in the morning and without like rolling out of bed again be like look i don't want to get my phone and all that like i'm going to see my text messages in my yeah right instead i would just like pull it out and like i'm gonna just read a chapter read read a few pages you know or in the evening the same thing And I'll say that it sounds so goofy and everyone says it and everyone's right, which is that you have less distractions on an e-reader. And the e-ink looks really good. So you can read it if you're in the sun or in the dark. And there's just not other things popping up and asking for your attention or distracting you. So I'll let you know at the end of the year.
But yeah, I too am striving to try to do a bit more reading. I am not returning into the office imminently. So yeah, I too need to fill that hole. Very cool. Yeah, I actually, so I was, I guess, thinking about just buying an e-paper like thing I could runux on or something like that um but uh but yeah maybe i should just go the road much much more traveled and buy kindle and not
cause so much heartache i was thinking that i would uh have an e-ink display that would be an e-reader but i could also use it as kind of a desk calendar and just leave it on my desk and it could show me my daily like schedule and maybe kindle can just do that so maybe someone's written that program for kindle i'm specifically trying not to do that so i will stay in the not distraction proper use of the thing for this one but but that does sound cool cool yeah um one thing that i did over the break, which I wanted to share with everybody is I, so I personally was spending like over $200 a month on public cloud stuff because I have, I have a whole bunch of sites.
I have, you know, programming throwdown. I also have a site for Mamehub. I have a server for Mamehub. I have a whole bunch of different projects all running on the cloud. And the thing that was really costing me a lot was databases, which is actually going to be one of the things that we're going to talk about, a part of what we're going to talk about today. But I was spending over $100 a month on databases. And some of these projects were either, you know, either dead or, you know, they were projects that we were running. Just at this point, just me and my family are using it.
And so I haven't really taken it mainstream or anything yet. And so I was able to really massively reduce the cost. So there's a whole like we could do a whole show on trying to reduce your cloud costs. But basically there's you know getting your own server so you have a server it's running you know ubuntu or debian or whatever and it's just there 24 7 and uh it's just sitting in you know google's data center amazon's data center what have you that's like the most expensive right right? And then there's, you know, getting a dedicated service. So like a database, you know, having a MySQL database kind of in the
cloud. And that, you know, they cut you a little bit of a deal if you go through like Amazon or Google, but still pretty expensive. I mean, for one server, you know, you're looking at, you know you're looking at you know at least like 50 a month and then there's the sort of uh like kind of pay as you go approach where you use things like aws lambda where you can say you know here's like a single python function and whenever the trigger happens i run this function but if there's no triggers then i'm not anything. And for a lot of the small projects I had, that would be way, way cheaper, right? Because a lot of these machines were sitting idle. But I didn't really know what there was in terms of databases. You know, is there a database where, you know, sure, if it got super popular, I could get
hit with a big bill, but, you know, I could at least be there until something got popular. And I found a couple which I wanted to share with everyone. So for SQL, for things like MySQL and Postgres and all of that, I'm using this thing called PlanetScale. And they have a very generous free tier. And then I think there's a flat fee. I want to say it's like $10 or $20 a month and you can get more databases and all of that.
But it's also a pretty generous flat fee. The thing is, if you start, they count the number of rows you access per second or per month, I guess. So if you start getting a lot of rows per month, I think it's like hundreds of thousands at that point, this is read or write at that point, they start charging you and then for object caching systems i'm using upstash which has like redis as a service and for the moment i'm still on the free version of upstash because i you know i'm not doing the caching too heavy yet but yeah i found both of these to be really nice and the way they've done it actually planet scale was clunky when I first tried it about six months ago, but I went back to it a week ago and it's now become extremely nice. It's very similar to just having a MySQL database.
There's really nothing you have to do special. But yeah, check these out. I think these are amazing projects. That's really cool. So that may or may not lead into stuff we talk about later, but database caching. But yeah, that's pretty cool. Have you ever thought about for some of that stuff, like the rage, well, at least my stuff I pay attention to would be like self-hosting some of that stuff, like having a computer you could just run Docker on and like letting people do that.
I mean, I don't know, depending on what usage patterns you have, I've been looking at this like WireGuard VPN as well, which would, there's a variety of people spinning up around that VPN, basically letting people appear as if they're in your home network, but easily for like relatives and stuff, even if you didn't want to expose it to the public web. Is that something you considered or just a bit too far off of what you normally do?
Yeah, I mean, the thing about it is it's actually kind of difficult to administer a MySQL server. You have to do a lot of setup. And then every time you update the OS, there's like a chance you break the server. So I ran Mamehub off just a regular VPS, like a regular machine in the cloud running Ubuntu. And so Mamehub had all of these things. It had MySQL, it had Redis, it had had everything running and it wasn't using docker probably should have been but yeah definitely without docker like you know it was breaking you know maybe like once a year or so i would have some big break or like the hard drive would fill up or something like that
there's just like all these small reasons where you could get kind of burned and then you have to kind of spin up on oh what did i do here and oh like you know the files i forgot what they are and everything so this this is nice because uh the worst thing that could happen is you can get hit with a high bill i do recommend folks turn on the uh there's a thing you can turn on where if the bill goes above a certain amount it shuts off i mean definitely take the five seconds to like go to the cost explorer and like set some ceiling on all of these things because you just never know i mean it could be like a dos attack or something and now all of a sudden you have some big bill but provided you do that
i mean these things will well should you know be up forever it's like upstash i set it up six months ago and to be honest i even forgot the name of the company or anything because I just, it just been working for six months. That's funny. Yeah. You remind me of the story of the guy when GPT-2 came out, the like natural language, deep learning trained model, and you could give it queries and he was doing like a sort of crude RPG over it where you could kind of just do anything you wanted and it would respond. And he was running it, I don't remember, I think on AWS or something. And it got super, super, super popular.
And I forget how obscene his server charges were initially. And same thing like you said. So I guess like that's always possible. So definitely try to make sure you set some sort of upper limit, even if it's pretty high, just so you don't end up waking up to a seven figure server charge. Yeah, I mean, you can easily end up with $100,000 bill. I mean, if you have some website that goes viral or gets DOSed, you could get hit with a huge bill. So it's definitely good advice to do that. Yeah, that's pretty funny. I think GPT-2 is not light.
I mean, it's a giant like hydra, you know, huge neural net. That's pretty wild. So what did he do? Did he negotiate his price down? Yeah, I mean, I think those ones that get like famous, famous, they sort of, you know, someone behind the scenes makes it
makes it not a big deal when a college student sort of says, oh, you know, I don't understand. it makes it not a big deal when a college student sort of says, Oh, you know, I don't understand. They don't want the bad press. So I'm sure behind the scenes, it just sort of got taken care of. And, you know, someone showed him politely how to set his his bill limits to something more reasonable. Yeah, that makes sense. But yeah, don't let that be you. Because I don't know what would happen if if you weren't famous or maybe they just didn't want to change the bill. Well, we've heard stories like this with cell phone, right? Where I remember a person was operating a crane in Alaska and they were roaming the whole time and they were streaming YouTube videos for like a month. They got some enormous bill like 70K or something. And yeah, that made the news too.
And I think they negotiated it down to 2000 or something. But yeah, be careful for that. That's always an issue. Speaking of reasons why you might also end up running unintentional code, this month has been pretty bad for Log4j. So this is Log4java. I've actually used this framework before. Yeah, same here.
Oh, okay. It's like super popular. And basically, it does a lot of really fancy stuff in Java to allow you to manage your logs, set verbosity levels and, you know, do smart tokenization so that you can insert, you know, data and just have better logging output, which logging is always just one of those things that's very difficult to kind of do really well. So Log4j as a framework was super, super popular. And of course, run in not exposed to the public, but on services that were exposed to the public, because pushing your logs up is one of the ways to debug if something goes wrong. And so making sure that, you know, servers are logging out information they're doing and that you can triage them is super critical. And they ran across three in the last, I think, sort of month vulnerabilities. And I was telling Jason before the show, we were talking about it's actually a bit difficult because it got so mainstream to find actual engineering discussion of what happened. But I have a couple of links in the show notes. And basically the exploit was
if you could insert a certain token into something you sent to the server and that token could get logged, Log4j would try to take action to unparse that token. And so I think Minecraft, for instance, got a lot of news because someday people are going to look back and talk about minecraft as you know rivaling the biggest things and crazes of the 80s and 90s oh yeah definitely for a long
time now it's crazy um how long minecraft has been going on jason and i you you and i played minecraft what 11 12 years ago or something i don't even know when it first came out like super long time ago now yeah it's still popular with kids today. Yeah. I was terrible at Minecraft. I mean, I just didn't have the patience really. Um, because I didn't realize that you had to look on the internet to find the crafting recipes. And so I tried a few different random putting things in the boxes and I couldn't figure out how to make the craft. I see. I think I, yeah, I couldn't even figure out how to make the crafting table. i was like okay you know i think we're done here there's no one's ever going to play this i remember you telling me about it on a work trip that had to
have been over a decade ago but anyway so minecraft super popular okay i was in a side back on topic and i think people were finding out you could send chats to each other in Minecraft. And if you send a chat that has a certain string, just like the classic, you know, SQL, uh, unescaped, um, unsanitized stuff and getting SQL exploits, you could say like, you know, dollar curly brace, and then some URL. And basically what would happen is log4j would go, Oh, I need to resolve this. Oh, this is a URL. I need to reach out to this URL to figure out the value of this variable and then the url could return a you know custom java bytecode class for you to run and that bytecode class we could just do anything and so this is obviously super super bad code injection wow wow it's wild this is like one one of those worst possible nightmare things. So I put in here some explanation from JFrog,
who they actually recently went public with Artifactory and stuff. But then also a link in here from Microsoft, which of course getting some of this heat from Minecraft, which all the Microsoft-hosted ones were patched very, very quickly. But we were just talking about hosting. Lots of other people are running Minecraft servers that are still vulnerable because they were relying on this vulnerable Java version.
But they were also discussing there how much logging they were seeing of people scanning for this vulnerability. So just hitting random endpoints with various things and trying to see if they could get pingbacks from your server, which would mean your server was vulnerable. And then they could decide what to do
once they had a list of all of the GC targets. How would they know if you're running log4j, whatever the service is? So, I mean, I think you could just find anyone, for instance, and it didn't go into this level of details. This is not my background. But I can imagine going to every IP address, going to port 80,
and then many of them are going to respond with some pre-canned server, something that you could recognize. And then sending back like, you know, Jason's whatever, oh, Mamehub. Mamehub.whateverjasonuses slash, you know, question mark equals, and then just putting like, you know, this format is streamed.
And many servers, it's very common to log the endpoint or to log the query params or whatever. And so if you have one of these in the query, I'm not 100% sure that would work. But you can imagine someone going to every port 80 exposed that had a signature that or fingerprint that matched some common open source host that uses log4j, inserting it into the query params, and then having a payload which says ping back my URL. And anyone who pings back, they would sort of insert into a database somewhere for later deciding what to do. Yeah, that totally makes sense. Yeah, I probably need to check Mamehub for this. But actually, Mamehub's running all Python and Flask and stuff, so I should be okay. Oh, probably okay.
Until it turns out, secretly, Flask is running some Java tool. Yeah, that's right. Flask has a module, a Python binding module. Yeah, that is wild, man. Very cool. Yeah, I always wondered that. Thanks for explaining all that. So my first article is scan of the month.
And this month, it's game boy there's some weirdness around the url but the url i posted in the chat should stand the test of time but they actually use ct and i don't know very much about i mean i know ostensibly mri is magnetic resonance i don't know actually what ct is isn't it computed tomography oh my gosh look at this man i put you on the spot and you nailed it i don't actually know under the hood like yeah what those really mean but but anyway they use ct to scan a bunch of computer components and this month they did a whole bunch of game boys like the game boy original the game boy color the ds the dsi Game Boy Color, the DS, the DSi.
And they use the CT scan to extract all different layers of PCB. And then they just go through explaining at a hardware level all the different components. And it's really cool to see over time how they kind of integrated everything. Like the earlier ones, it's it's like okay here's all the buttons and here's the d-pad and there's little traces going to all over the place and then and then later on it's like okay we just have this chip that's doing everything and and like literally all the traces are just going to this one place or they're baked into the board or what have you um but yeah check it out i, I don't know very much about
hardware. I got a really kick out of reading this and the graphics are beautiful. It should work on the phone and on the computer. So I read it on the phone and yeah, give it, give it a read. It'll be worth five minutes. Yeah, that, those, the artwork in there is really cool the way they did it. The presentation of the website is fun, but it definitely, definitely has a pretty pictures. Something that I was surprised about and it turns out it's rather common. So not, not CT scans. I mean, there's a, there's a very involved, but x-ray actually for people who do a lot of like electronics assembly, it's very common to x-ray boards and look for defects.
So when they make the printed circuit boards, like the, you know, where all the traces are, you have multiple layers. So you can only see stuff that's on the sort of like exterior layer, the bottom layer and the top layer, but you can have middle layers. So I think for like your motherboard in your computer, it's common to have five plus layers internally, like over top of each other, routing, ground planes, all this stuff. And you can't see that from the outside. So if there's a break or an issue, you wouldn't be able to detect it. So it's actually very common to do x-rays of electronics and look for, you know, places where a trace is broken or isn't routed correctly or something is happening. And so doing those kind of, I thought that was limited to when you go to the dentist and they do the,
you know, x-ray. But apparently doing sort go to the dentist and they do the x-ray. But apparently doing sort of real-time on-demand x-rays is more common than I would have thought. Yeah, that's wild. I didn't realize x-ray would be that precise. My next news topic is not really a news topic, but something that came up and then it was alluded to by some article I wrote. So I decided to talk about it here, which is Hiram's Law. Have you heard this before, Jason? No, I haven't. So, okay, I'm going to read it directly or else I'll end up misquoting it. So Hiram's Law says that with a sufficient number of users of an API, it does not matter what you promise in the
contract. All observable behaviors of your system will be depended on by somebody. So this comes up from time to time. When you do software engineering, there always is like mythical man month, Hiram's law, the networking issues. You get into all sorts of things where everyone keeps rediscovering it. And this is one of those ones that I had run across, but didn't have a name for it. Now I have a name for it. And it's Hiram's law, which is if you make your system behave in a certain way, if enough, if it gets popular enough, everyone will depend on every quirk intended or unintended of that system. And so the person, you can go to the website credit sort of where they got it from and these kinds of things.
But people were chiming in an article I was reading with all manner of examples. So if you go back to like the old Nintendo, the NES, that like certain quirks of how the graphics rendering became like super important. So in a later revision, if they had fixed the silicon and fixed that quote unquote bug, everything would have stopped working.
There are certain weird op codes or low level device drivers that just do certain things at certain time, because that's the way to always work. But then you can't change it because everyone does it that way. And so if you fixed it later, you'd break other people's stuff. And it doesn't matter whether you wrote that down or not, if it behaves that way, it's going to act that way. We ran across this recently, and I was bringing it up to somebody. It's not exactly the same, but in the same ballpark, which is somebody was iterating a hash map. Of course, like the how
things are inserted to the hash map could vary for many reasons, but it shouldn't be something you ever rely on. It isn't a contractual obligation for like, if you insert in a different order, if you do whatever, if you need a stable visit order, you have to do some sort of sorting or some guaranteed way. And HashMap is not that. Yeah. I think in Python, there's like a special structure called, it's either called stable HashMap or ordered HashMap. I think it's called ordered hash map and so ordered hash map when you iterate over the keys you get them in the order you put them in i still don't understand why anyone would want that it keeps like a linked list like it must yeah it must keep a link list in addition to the map in the background okay i mean sure but but needless to say so so we ran
across a test where someone was putting stuff in a hash map, iterating the hash map, and then basically asserting in a kind of like unit test that like the results were in this order. And I pointed out to them like, this is really bad, like super fragile, like, you know, this is overly simplified. Or sort it afterwards or something. Sort it, do something or do a check where you don't rely on the sorting, just check that it's present, right? Because yeah, that iteration can change at any time. But I think you could easily imagine building two or three layers up
to where when you call an API, you say like, give me a random user, but actually the random user always gives you a sorted list. Somebody somewhere isn't going to realize it was supposed to give you a random user. And they're going to assume that if they keep calling it, they always get them sorted. And they're going to depend on it being sorted because it's never been otherwise. So this is putting a name on one of those things I've always kind of known for years and run across many times.
But it's good to have a common language for it. Yeah, we see this a lot. So a lot of people are curious when they find out that MAME actually gets more and more inefficient as you move up in the versions of MAME. So for example, like the most recent version of MAME can't run on a Raspberry Pi, but you can run MAME from 10 years ago just fine.
And even the same game will run just fine and even you know the same game will run just fine if you're on the current mame it won't work and the reason for that is because of all of these things where you know they kind of use various tricks to take advantage of you know the way the hardware was set up and so you have to emulate kind of all of these tricks perfectly and it becomes really time consuming and there's a one in particular people should check this out in contra the arcade version of contra in the actual arcade the bullets would flicker but the flickering was caused by just the different processors running at different speeds and so they just thought it kind of looked cool
or maybe they shouldn't you know didn't have time to fix it. And so they kept it. But for a long time in MAME, the bullets would not flicker. And so they actually did all this work to make them flicker and it became really computationally expensive to do that.
But yeah, it's similar to this law where it's like people either took advantage or they took artistic liberty with the situation that they had on the hardware side. And then recreating that ends up being really hard. My second story is make the Internet yours again with an instant mesh network. So I haven't tried this full disclaimer, but I love the idea just to give a bit of backstory. So, you know, a long time ago, they invented IPv6.
And the reason why IPv6 is cool is because, you know, well, OK, if you go back even further, every machine had a public IP address for that machine. So I don't know how far back you have to go for this to be true. But, you know, you would have, you you know 27.27.27.27 like that was you and so anytime anyone you know ping that they would get your computer that you're you know on right now or your phone or whatever you're on right now when you're listening to this and so you could just run a web server or an email server on your device and that's it. You'd be done. It's like, okay, I have my web server on 24. Anyone can just go there and see my website. Well, people started
running out of IP addresses because there's a lot, right? There's 256. Well, the number space is 256 to the fourth. A lot of those addresses you can't use for a variety of reasons, but there's still a decent chunk of addresses, but not enough compared to the number of machines that we have on the planet Earth. Right. It's not even close. So and all the machines that have ever existed because you don't really you don't really know when a machine has been decommissioned. Right. So they proposed IPv6. And this just adds a ton of bytes, bits to the address space. And so with IPv6, in theory, every machine could be accessed directly. So you could have a machine that's at your house
and someone out there on the internet, an internet cafe could just like go to that machine and just see what ports are open and everything. And so, yeah, one thing to keep in mind is, you know, because, so actually just doubling back a bit. So to deal with this address space issue, we created NATs, Network Address Translators.
So, you know, a portion of the internet address space is blocked off for internal addresses. And so, for example, in my house, you know, everything is 192.168.something.something. And anything after 192.168 is going to be some internal place. Could be someone's house, could be, you know, a business, right? But there's, there's maybe hundreds of thousands of devices that have the IP address, you know, 192.168.0. I guess that's to be at least one. So 192.168.0.1, there's tons and tons of devices with that address. But what happens underneath is, is machines go to, let's say, your house. So let's say one of these machines with the same address tries to reach google.com. They ping Google and all the machines on the way keep track that that machine wanted to talk to Google. So let's say you have 192.168.0.1 is your phone.
所以，你知道，一部分互联网地址空间被划分为内部地址。因此，举个例子，在我家里，你知道，所有东西都是 192.168.某.某。任何在 192.168 之后的都将是某个内部位置。可能是某人的家，可能是，你知道，一家企业，对吧？但可能有成千上万的设备拥有 IP 地址，你知道，192.168.0。我想至少应该有一个。所以 192.168.0.1，有成吨成吨的设备使用该地址。但在底层发生的事情是，机器会访问，比方说，你家。所以假设其中一台拥有相同地址的机器试图连接 google.com。它们向 Google 发送 ping 请求，途中的所有机器都会记录下那台机器想要与 Google 通信。所以假设你的手机是 192.168.0.1。
Your phone talks to your router, which is running on, let's say, that address dot two. And the router keeps track of that phone wanting to reach Google. And then that router then goes to your ISP. Your ISP has another router. It's just the same thing. And then when Google replies with their logo and all of that, all these machines know who needed it. And there's a whole bunch of complexity around that.
你的手机与你的路由器通信，假设该路由器的地址是点二。路由器会记录下这部手机想要连接 Google 的请求。然后该路由器接着访问你的 ISP。你的 ISP 有另一个路由器。原理完全一样。然后当 Google 带著他们的标志以及所有这些内容回复时，所有这些机器都知道是谁需要它。这背后有相当多的复杂性。
But that's how that translation works. The problem is there's no way to go the other way. So if Google wants to send a message to your phone, that isn't a reply. That's just an organic first message. They don't know which 192.168.0.1 is your phone and not someone else's. And so there's just no way for them to talk to your phone. Now, that's good for a security perspective, but it's bad from a, you know, running a server or doing something, you know, distributed hash table or anything like that in your house. And so what this
但这就是这种转换工作的方式。问题在于，没有办法反向进行。因此，如果 Google 想给你的手机发送一条消息，那不是一条回复。那只是一条自发的首条消息。它们不知道哪个 192.168.0.1 是你的手机，而不是别人的。因此，它们根本无法与你的手机通信。现在，从安全角度来看这很好，但从，你知道，运行服务器或做一些，你知道，分布式哈希表或你家里的任何类似事情的角度来看，这很糟糕。因此，这个
system does, it has a weird name. It's named after one of the HP Lovecraft monsters, like Yggdrasil or something. Isn't Yggdrasil the Nordic Tree of Life? Oh, okay. It is, yeah. Norse mythology. Oh, isn't there
系统所做的事情，它有一个奇怪的名字。它是以其中一个洛夫克拉夫特（HP Lovecraft）怪物命名的，比如克苏鲁（Yggdrasil）什么的。伊格d拉西尔（Yggdrasil）难道不是北欧生命之树吗？哦，好吧。是的，确实是。北欧神话。哦，难道没有
an HP Lovecraft monster that sounds very similar? That's Cthulhu? No, no, there's one that starts, I think, with that. Let me look it up. I think Yggdrasil is a Nordic tree of life. But anyways, continue. With branches and connectivity, I think it probably goes along with the... Oh, it's actually, there's one just called Yt.
一个听起来非常相似的洛夫克拉夫特怪物吗？那是克苏鲁（Cthulhu）？不，不，有一个名字，我想，是以那个开头的。让我查一下。我以为伊格d拉西尔（Yggdrasil）是北欧的生命之树。但无论如何，继续。有枝桠和连通性，我想它可能和……哦，实际上，有一个就叫 Yt。
Oh, I know. Oh, yeah, so they probably just stole it from that but uh anyways so overload yeah yeah they overloaded yeah they needed ipv6 for their you know monster names but yeah so check this out i mean you know as as i said it's going to basically make your any machine that runs this is going to be exposed to any other machine in the whole world that's running this and so what that means is you probably want like a firewall or just like you know if you're running a server or something you want to be really careful about this you know some people at their house they might run a samba or a network file share and leave it totally
哦，我知道。哦，是的，所以他们大概只是从那里偷来的，但无论如何，重载，Yeah，Yeah，他们重载了，Yeah，他们需要 IPv6 来命名他们的怪物，但 Yeah，所以看看这个，我的意思是，你知道，正如我所说，它基本上会使运行它的任何机器都暴露给全世界运行它的任何其他机器，所以这意味着你可能想要一个防火墙，或者只是像，你知道，如果你正在运行一个服务器或类似的东西，你想要对此非常小心，你知道，有些人回到家可能会运行一个 Samba 或网络文件共享，并且由于这个原因将其完全
unprotected because of this. They don't have to worry about this address translation or the address translation is kind of protecting them. This will kind of strip off all of those protections. So, you know, use this, kind of understand what you're doing. Maybe run it in a Docker container first. But yeah, I thought this was really cool. And I think the reason why IPv6 has never really taken off is all of the security nightmares that would be downstream from that.
置于未保护状态。他们不必担心这种地址转换，或者说地址转换在某种程度上保护了他们。这会在某种程度上剥离掉所有这些保护。所以，你知道，使用这个时，要明白自己在做什么。也许先在一个 Docker 容器中运行它。但是 Yeah，我觉得这个真的很酷。而且我认为 IPv6 从未真正流行起来的原因，是所有随之而来的下游安全噩梦。
But yeah, this will allow you to, without having to do a lot of complicated port forwarding, just access all the machines in your house from anywhere, which I think is kind of cool. Is it time for Book of the Show? Book of the Show. My Book of the Show is kind of cool. Is it time for book of the show? Book of the show. My book of the show is an amazing book. I've loved this about halfway through it. And I'm a really, really big fan. I love the format. I think they did an amazing job with this.
但是 Yeah，这将允许你，无需进行大量复杂的端口转发，就可以从任何地方访问你家里的所有机器，我觉得这挺酷的。是时候进入“本期图书”（Book of the Show）了吗？本期图书。我的本期图书挺酷的。是时候进入本期图书了吗？本期图书。我的本期图书是一本惊艳的书。读到大约一半时我就爱不释手了。我真的是个超级超级大的粉丝。我很喜欢这个版式。我觉得他们在这方面做得太棒了。
It's called AI 2041. And the premise behind the book is they're outlining different things that they think could be real in 2041, where AI has just advanced like a massive clip. The book is broken up into chapters. Every odd chapter is a independent story. Because it's a set of short stories, I can't, you know, I don't want to spoil any of them. You know, there isn't a plot that covers the whole book. It's like, think of it, each odd number chapter
这本书叫《AI 2041》（AI 2041）。这本书的设想是，他们勾勒出他们认为在 2041 年可能成为现实的不同事物，那时人工智能正以惊人的速度发展。这本书分为几个章节。每一个奇数章都是一个独立的故事。因为这是一组短篇小说，我不能，你知道，我不想剧透任何一个。你知道，没有一个贯穿全书的情节。就像，这样想，把每一个奇数编号的章节
as its own small book with its own beginning and end. And then every even chapter is Kai-Fu Lee who ran the Google Asia Research, Google Research Asia. And he goes through and explains the technology in the chapter you had just finished. And he kind through and explains the technology in the chapter you had just finished. And he kind of like explains it as if you're a total lay person. I mean, he goes into what is a neural network and everything. So I found that like really, really cool, like dynamics.
当作它自己的小书，有它自己的起承转合。然后每一个偶数章是由李开复撰写的，他曾管理过 Google 亚洲研究院（Google Research Asia）。他会通读并解释你刚刚读完的那一章中的技术。他会通读并解释你刚刚读完的那一章中的技术。而且他的解释方式就像是在面对一个完全的外行。我的意思是，他深入讲解了什么是神经网络等等。所以我发现这是一种非常非常酷的动态。
So the stories are all fiction stories, obviously. But not only that, they're dramatic. So without spoiling too much, there's a story about these twins who their parents are killed in a car accident, you know, when they're babies. And so they get taken to an orphanage. And it's about them growing up in this orphanage and how, you know, AI has massively improved sort of education. And especially in like kind of orphanage situations, you know, they, they have sort of these AIs that kind of care for them, like in addition to the people and everything. So yeah, I mean, it's, it's like, I could see kind of something like that happening where, where AI
所以这些故事显然都是虚构的故事。不仅如此，它们还是戏剧性的。所以不剧透太多的话，有一个故事讲的是一对双胞胎，他们的父母在他们还是婴儿的时候在一场车祸中丧生，你知道的。于是他们被带到了一家孤儿院。这个故事讲述了他们在这家孤儿院里长大，以及人工智能是如何极大地改善教育的。特别是在孤儿院这种情况下，你知道，他们除了有人照顾之外，还有某种人工智能在照顾他们。所以，Yeah，我的意思是，这就好像，我可以想象类似的事情发生，在那里 AI
can be sort of like a teddy bear, like a buddy for somebody as their, as their little, and all of them are plausible. I mean, I definitely think that they really push to the limit how much progress we would have to make. But nothing is totally fantastic. Like everything I think is doable in 20 years. And at least from the chapters I've read so far. One chapter, which I thought was kind of funny, was there was a person who or they're a driver for self-driving cars. So the idea is, you know, self-driving car gets stuck in an intersection and this person sits in their house and they have a steering wheel and a computer and their whole job nine to five is just taking over
可以某种程度上像一只泰迪熊，像一个伴侣，作为他们的小伙伴，并且所有这些都是合理的。我的意思是，我绝对认为他们确实将我们必须取得的进展推到了极限。但没有任何东西是完全异想天开的。就像我认为一切在 20 年内都是可行的。至少从我目前读到的章节来看是这样的。其中一个章节，我觉得挺搞笑的，是一个人，或者说他们是自动驾驶汽车的安全员。所以这个想法是，你知道，自动驾驶汽车卡在了一个路口，这个人坐在家里，手握方向盘和电脑，他们朝九晚五的全部工作就是接管
from cars that are stuck. And so they're, they were recanting kind of their career. And when their career started, it's like, oh, a car is stuck at a stop sign. It's just confused. And so he just takes over. He just, you know, looks around using all of his monitors. There's no one in the intersection.
那些卡住的汽车。所以他们当时在回顾他们的职业生涯。当他们的职业生涯开始时，就好像，哦，一辆车卡在了一个停车标志前。它只是糊涂了。于是他直接接管。他只是，你知道，利用他所有的显示器四处查看。路口没有人。
He just drives on and then he hands the control back to the AI. But now it's 2041, right? I mean, it's, I don't know, 15 years later or something from when this person got their job. And so now the situations they're in are just crazy. It's like, oh, the car needs you to take over. And he jumps in and the car's like on fire, you know? And so his job has turned into doing just crazy things all day, just like deftifying things all day. And he gets some PTSD from it.
他径直把车开过去，然后把控制权交还给 AI。但现在是 2041 年了，对吧？我的意思是，这，我不知道，距离这个人找到工作已经过去 15 年左右了。所以现在他们所处的境地简直疯狂。就像，哦，车需要你接管。他跳进去，结果车着火了，你知道的？所以他的工作已经变成了整天做一些疯狂的事情，整天拆除炸弹一样排险。并且他因此患上了一些创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。
So I don't know. I think the whole book is really interesting. Highly recommend it. Oh, that is not good. I'm going to add that to my list. Yeah, you can read it on your Kindle and let us know how it is. There we go.
所以我不知道。我觉得整本书真的非常有趣。强烈推荐。哦，那可真不妙。我要把它加到我的书单里。Yeah，你可以在你的 Kindle 上阅读它，然后让我们知道感觉如何。就这样。
So talking about books I read on my Kindle, which I've never read any illustrated books. I don't know how that works yet. But I read Dawnshard by brandon sanderson so um as if if you know anything about brandon sanderson his prolific writer but also his books tend to be kind of long and as if they weren't uh sort of long enough the uh current series that i've been working on the stormlight archives is supposed to be 10 books in total two two five-part books. But then between each set of books he releases, he's releasing a novella between them. And so this is the one between the third and fourth book, The Words of
所以说到我在 Kindle 上读的书，我从来没读过任何带插图的书。我还不知道那该怎么运作。但我读了布兰登·桑德森（Brandon Sanderson）的《破晓碎片》（Dawnshard）。所以，嗯，如果，如果你对布兰登·桑德森有所了解的话，他是一位多产的作家，但同时他的书往往也挺长的。就好像它们还不够长一样，我目前正在看的这个系列《飓光档案馆》（The Stormlight Archives）总共应该是 10 本书，分为两套五部曲。但在他发布每套书之间，他都会在中间发布一本中篇小说。所以这是第三部和第四部书《王者之路》（Words of
Radiance and Rhythm of War. So it's a novella, but it's's still i guess i'm looking here on the internet says 270 pages 269 pages so 269 pages is considered like the short book between the like other books on either side of it oh my gosh it's like three point book 3.5 um but book four itself i mean the rhythm of war i forgot it's like 1200 pages i think we were talking about it before um so anyways i read this on my kindle a lower commitment than reading full Rhythm of War, which is what I've started now. But this was an easier thing. And I read it and this book was really good. Obviously not a recommendation for people who haven't read books 1, 1.5, 2, 2.5, 3, and now 3.5. But you know, if you're in that series, definitely worth a read.
Radiance）和《战争节奏》（Rhythm of War）之间的那本。所以它是一本中篇小说，但我看网上的资料说有 270 页，269 页，所以 269 页被认为是夹在两边其他书中间的那本“短书”。哦天哪，这就像是 3.5 本书，呃……但第四本书本身，我的意思是《战争节奏》，我忘了，好像有 1200 页，我想我们之前讨论过。所以，无论如何，我在 Kindle 上读了这本，比读完整的《战争节奏》投入要低，我现在才开始读《战争节奏》。但这更容易读完。我读了，这本书真的很好。显然，对于还没读过第 1 本、1.5 本、第 2 本、2.5 本、第 3 本以及现在的 3.5 本书的人来说，这不是一个推荐。但你知道的，如果你正在追这个系列，绝对值得一读。
Some people don't read the in-between novellas, but I like to because if you don't, I feel like you miss stuff. So I enjoyed this. This is one of those important and good for me and people in the know, but everyone else is like, yeah, this is not a useful recommendation
有些人不读中间的中篇小说，但我喜欢读，因为如果你不读，我觉得你会错过一些东西。所以我很喜欢这本。这是那种对我以及懂行的人来说很重要且很好的书，但其他人可能会觉得，Yeah，这不是一个有用的推荐
because I'm not gonna jump in at the middle of this huge, long, many thousand page epic. So. Well, I've definitely, we've gotten emails from people I'm not going to jump in at the middle of this huge, long, many thousand page epic. Well, no, I've definitely, we've gotten emails from people who either got into, you know, your interests, your reading interests. They've like adopted some of your reading interests or they're already there and the show really connects with them. Yeah, I've gotten some recommendations from people as well for good series that I've read. Unfortunately, my reading was, as we talked about at the top of the show has been severely diminished recently. So I'm trying to get back on the train. Got to make it through my backlog.
因为我不会从这个巨大、漫长、数千页史诗的中间插足进去。所以。嗯，我绝对，我们收到过来自那些我不会从这个巨大、漫长、数千页史诗的中间插足进去的人的电子邮件。好吧，不，我绝对，我们收到过来自那些开始接触，你知道的，你们的兴趣、你的阅读兴趣的人的电子邮件。他们采纳了你的一些阅读兴趣，或者他们本来就在追，这个节目真的很契合他们。Yeah，我也收到过一些人关于我读过的好系列的推荐。不幸的是，正如我们在节目开头所讨论的，我的阅读量最近严重减少了。所以我正试图重新回到正轨上。得把积压的书单看完。
Cool, man. All right. On to the tool of the show. Let's go. I wonder if we should pay, like, get an announcer or use Amazon Polly or something to get a real announcer voice? Or we should just keep doing that. Let us know. Send us an email.
酷，伙计。好的。进入本期工具。我们走。我在想我们是不是应该付费，比如找个播音员或者用 Amazon Polly 之类的来做一个真正的播音员声音？还是我们应该继续这样做？让我们知道。给我们发封电子邮件。
A horribly bad fiver. Yeah. Do you want us to pay an announcer to do that? Or I wonder if Amazon Polly has an announcer voice where you could just type something into Amazon Polly and it would... I don't know what this is. Oh, Amazon Polly is just a speech synthesis program. Oh, yeah, there it is.
一个糟糕透顶的 Fiver（播音员）。Yeah。你想让我们花钱请播音员来做那个吗？或者我在想 Amazon Polly 是否有一个播音员的声音，你可以把一些东西打进 Amazon Polly，然后它就会……我不知道这是什么。哦，Amazon Polly 只是一个语音合成程序。哦，是的，就是这样。
Yeah, so my tool of the show, which is never going to sound as cool for me as it does from an announcer guy, is Swagger, which is now rebranded as OpenAPI, or at least part of it. So I used Swagger a long time ago, and it's really come a long way. I was working with another team at work that had a Swagger, had their stuff running in Swagger. It was really impressive. And so basically, the way it works is, you know, if you want to, you know, have a web service, so something where someone gives you some input, you know, some set of arguments, some JSON output and then on your actual server,
所以，我的本期工具，它对我来说永远不会像从一个播音员那里听起来那么酷，就是 Swagger，它现在已经重新品牌化为 OpenAPI，或者至少是它的一部分。所以我很久以前就用过 Swagger，它确实取得了很大的进步。我当时在公司和另一个团队合作，他们的 Swagger 正在运行他们的东西。这真的很让人印象深刻。所以基本上，它的工作原理是，你知道，如果你想，你知道的，拥有一个网络服务（web service），也就是别人给你一些输入，你知道的，一些参数集，一些 JSON 输出，然后在你实际的服务器上，
you could be doing whatever. You want something that is pretty standard, right? Because you don't know what languages people are going to be using when they're calling your service. And so you can imagine just like, yeah, taking in a JSON blob and then outputting a JSON blob. But then the problem with that is it gets really generic. Like people could put anything. They might mistype one of the keys, right, of your JSON object. They might just have a typo in there. And so that becomes kind of difficult to debug.
你可以做任何你想做的事。你想要一些相当标准的东西，对吧？因为你不知道当人们调用你的服务时会使用什么语言。所以你可以想象，就像是，Yeah，接收一个 JSON 数据块，然后输出一个 JSON 数据块。但这样做的问题在于它变得非常通用。就像人们可能会输入任何东西。他们可能会拼错你的 JSON 对象的键之一，对吧？他们里面可能就有一个拼写错误。因此这变得有点难以调试。
Like you have to write all sorts of logic to handle that. And then also to, you know, make sure you produce the right documentation. So you tell people, you know, when you call, because they probably won't be able to see your source code or it'll be, you know, cumbersome for them to have to go through your source code. So you want to be able to tell them like, look, you know, I expect this, you know, JSON object and I expect this key called foobar and the F needs to be capitalized and etc. And so Swagger is a way for you to sort of write up that contract and then it'll automatically generate, you know, a website where people can go and, you know, read more about how your API works.
就像你必须编写各种逻辑来处理这个问题。而且还要，你知道的，确保你生成了正确的文档。所以你告诉人们，你知道，当你调用时，因为他们可能看不到你的源代码，或者让他们去浏览你的源代码会很麻烦。所以你希望能够告诉他们，看，你知道的，我期望得到这个，你知道的，JSON 对象，我期望有一个叫 foobar 的键，而且 F 需要是大写的，等等。所以 Swagger 是一种让你编写这种契约的方式，然后它会自动生成，你知道的，一个网站，人们可以在那里访问并，你知道的，阅读更多关于你的 API 如何工作的信息。
And then this is where, you know, I don't want to spend too much time on this, but basically, you know, they created this standard called OpenAI. There's a whole bunch of tooling. There's tools that Swagger, the company has that lets you test your API, you know, from the outside and everything. So definitely check this out. If you're building a service that you either you want to consume from some other language or, you know, you want, you're building something for other people, definitely check these things out. They're super powerful. I've used some stuff that had this.
然后这就是，你知道的，我不想在这里花太多时间，但基本上，你知道的，他们创建了这个名为 OpenAPI 的标准。这里有一大堆工具。有一些工具是 Swagger 这家公司拥有的，可以让你从外部测试你的 API 诸如此类的一切。所以一定要看看这个。如果你正在构建一个你想从其他语言调用的服务，或者，你知道的，你正在为其他人构建东西，一定要看看这些东西。它们超级强大。我用过一些带有这个的东西。
I've not written a ton of the sort of, what would you call that? The metadata you need to generate them. Although I have a little. Yeah, I guess. But I've used that or something. Okay. But I have used some that had it.
我没有写过很多那种，你会怎么称呼它？生成它们所需的元数据。虽然我写过一点。是的，我猜吧。但我用过那个或类似的东西。好的。但我确实用过一些带有这个功能的。
I do really like this thing you're saying where you can sort of go to it and have it guide you through what you're expected to send, then get back and super powerful. And I can imagine like keep going this way and then having tools to like auto-complete your code for like how the expression should come in and like what's expected and not when you start linking to serve, like one day, we're not there, but like one day in my head, it's going to be a beautiful place where everything's going yeah
我真的很喜欢你说的这一点，你可以访问它，让它引导你了解你应该发送什么，然后得到回报，超级强大。我可以想象，就像继续这样下去，然后拥有诸如自动补全代码的工具，比如表达式应该如何进来以及什么是期望的，什么不是，当你开始链接到服务器时，有一天，我们还没到那一步，但在我脑海里的某一天，这将是一个美好的地方，一切都会……Yeah
that's a genius idea i bet someone's written that like a visual studio code extension where you kind of give it the swagger url like the you know the documentation url that you're trying to you know access and then they could do they could do tabbing for you and so that would be amazing if you're out there and you're looking for something to build and then they could do tabbing for you. And so that would be amazing. If you're out there and you're looking for something to build and this doesn't exist yet, that would be phenomenal. And it probably wouldn't be that hard to build. Ooh, famous last words.
这是一个绝妙的主意。我打赌有人已经写过类似的东西了，比如一个 Visual Studio Code 扩展，你把 Swagger URL 传给它，就像你试图（你知道的）访问的文档 URL 一样，然后他们可以为你做标签页补全（tabbing），所以如果你正在寻找要构建的东西，那将是惊人的，并且他们可以为你做标签页补全。所以如果你正在寻找要构建的东西而这还不存在的话，那将是现象级的。而且构建它可能没那么难。噢，名言警句（著名最后的遗言）。
We can't guarantee that last part. My tool of the show, I thought I mentioned it before. I couldn't find it. If I did, oh, well, it's worth mentioning again. I haven't heard of it. Oh, really? Okay. This is RipGraph.
我们不能保证最后一部分。我的本期工具，我以为我之前提到过。我没找到。如果我提过，哦，好吧，那值得再次提及。我没听说过。哦，真的吗？好吧。这就是 RipGraph。
Now, you're probably sitting there like Jason saying, I use only the most powerful, awesome Unix tools, and I don't need anything that isn't POSIX compliant and shipped with my BSD install. I'm not such a user. So I have found this tool enormously helpful for searching around my code. Ripgrep promises to do a lot of things,
现在，你可能坐在那里，就像杰森（Jason）一样说，我只使用最强大、最棒的 Unix 工具，我不需要任何不符合 POSIX 标准且随我的 BSD 安装附带的东西。我不是那种用户。所以我发现这个工具在我的代码周围进行搜索时非常有用。Ripgrep 承诺做很多事情，
many of them interesting, including being faster. But the thing I love Ripgrep for is that I can search the directories I have recursively by default, and also honoring my get ignores and ignoring binary by default. Now I'm 100% sure you can do the same thing with grep. I don't know how fast or slow it would be. But that incantation is beyond me. So I can do rip grep, which I have is just RG and then pass it a dash I flag if I wanted to ignore the capitalization of my query,
其中许多都很有趣，包括速度更快。但我喜欢 Ripgrep 的原因在于，我可以默认递归搜索我拥有的目录，并且默认遵循我的 gitignore 并默认忽略二进制文件。现在我 100% 确定你可以用 grep 做同样的事情。我不知道它会有多快或多慢。但那种咒语对我来说太难了。所以我可以使用 rip grep，我把它简称为 rg，然后如果我想忽略查询的大小写，就传递一个 -I 标志，
type in the word I want to search for, and get back in my Git repositories all the places I've used that keyword. Wow, this is so cool. Yeah. Apparently, there's a bunch of other tools that were listed there that I learned about from going to their website in preparation from here, things like Silver Surfer and other things that I guess also do the same thing, but I've never used those. RipGrep says it's faster than all of them. The speed is good. I've never been bothered by that,
输入我要搜索的单词，并在我的 Git 仓库中找回我使用过该关键词的所有地方。哇，这太酷了。Yeah。显然，还有一堆其他工具列在那里，我是为了准备这个节目去访问他们的网站时了解到的，比如 Silver Surfer 和其他我猜也做同样事情的东西，但我从未使用过那些。RipGrep 说它比所有这些都快。速度很好。我从来没有为此烦恼过，
but just this ability to automatically ignore binary files, automatically ignore things. For instance, we have build folders that hold outputs. And whenever you search, if you forget, and you just type grep, and then you do it recursively, you end up getting a lot of outputs from the build folder, you know, inputs that were copied or zip file, whatever, all these kinds of things.
但仅仅是这种自动忽略二进制文件、自动忽略某些东西的能力。例如，我们有保存输出的构建文件夹。每当你搜索时，如果你忘记了，只是输入 grep，然后递归执行，你最终会从构建文件夹中获得大量的输出，你知道，被复制的输入或 zip 文件，无论是什么，所有这些类型的东西。
And you don't want them. And so rip grep will ignore them because they're ignored and they get ignored. And so that's super powerful. And also it does have ability, which again, probably can do in other things,
而你并不想要它们。所以 rip grep 会忽略它们，因为它们在 gitignore 中被忽略了。所以这超级强大。而且它还具有某种能力，同样，这可能可以在其他东西中做到，
but to like go into even compressed stuff. So if you were trying to search dependencies and you're using something which brings in dependencies as compressed, then it'll be able to handle those things as well. Wow, you know, that is amazing. I'm definitely gonna use this. So the other thing that this site had,
比如甚至进入压缩的内容中。因此，如果你试图搜索依赖项，并且你使用的是将依赖项作为压缩文件引入的东西，那么它也能够处理这些事情。哇，你知道，这太惊人了。我绝对要用这个。所以这个网站还有另一件事，
which blew my mind is there's grep inside of git So you can type git space grep space and then do grep inside of git. I Also didn't know that but does that work if you're not in a git repo like yeah, I have like something it's only for git repos Okay. So the problem is sometimes I have like a directory with multiple git repos in it and I don't know Which one of my projects I was doing that thing in so but yeah no i also learned that from there yes wow super cool learn something new every day yeah i should check this out rip grip it's probably like you can just app to get it or something yeah i'm on mac os so i just brew installed it oh yeah there you go yeah it looks like it says windows lin, Linux, and macOS support.
这让我大开眼界，那就是 git 里面有 grep。所以你可以输入 git space grep space，然后在 git 里面做 grep。我以前也不知道这一点。但如果你不在一个 git 仓库中，这管用吗？就像，Yeah，我有些东西它只适用于 git 仓库。好吧。所以问题有时是我有一个包含多个 git 仓库的目录，我不知道我在哪一个项目中做那个事情，但是，Yeah，不，我也从那里学到了这一点。Yes，哇，超级酷。每天学到新东西。Yeah，我应该看看这个 rip grip，大概就像你可以用 apt-get 安装它一样。Yeah，我在 macOS 上，所以我直接 brew install 了。哦，Yeah，原来如此。Yeah，看起来它支持 Windows、Linux 和 macOS。
Yeah, Windows, Linux, Arch, Gen 2, Fedora. They did everything except Debian. Where are we, Debian? Oh, yeah, there you go. Yeah, you can apt-get install it. Okay, cool. All right, so if Jason's voice gets funny here for a minute, it's because he's downloading... Yeah, that's right, yeah.
Yeah，Windows、Linux、Arch、Gentoo、Fedora。他们支持了除了 Debian 之外的一切。我们在哪儿，Debian？哦，Yeah，原来如此。Yeah，你可以 apt-get install 它。好的，酷。好吧，如果杰森的声音在这里变得有些滑稽，那是因为他在下载……Yeah，没错，Yeah。
If I start doing that weird thing where your voice becomes really robotic, it's because my Internet is totally used up downloading Ripgrip. Cool. All right. We'll jump into the topic. Maybe we should start with why these things exist, which I think is always a good place to start. Object caching systems. I'll give an example to illustrate why we need something like this. I recently built a replacement for Google Photos. So I built, you know, Jason
如果我开始发出那种让你的声音变得非常机械的奇怪声音，那是因为我的互联网完全被下载 Ripgrip 占满了。酷。好的。我们跳进主题。也许我们应该从这些东西为什么存在开始，我认为这总是一个很好的切入点。对象缓存系统。我举个例子来说明为什么我们需要这样的东西。我最近构建了一个 Google Photos 的替代品。所以我构建了，你知道，Jason
Gauchi Photos. And I convinced my wife to install it. And so now her phone crashes like every hour on the hour. And she's not super thrilled with that. So I'm definitely not recommending it to the audience yet. But the idea is it would periodically scan your phone for new photos. And if you're on Wi-Fi, it would push them to the cloud. And then I also had an app, have an app where you can go in. And very similar to Google Photos, you can kind of see all your photos. So the way the app works and the way
Gauchi Photos。我劝说我妻子安装了它。所以现在她的手机每隔一小时整就会崩溃一次。她对这可不太高兴。所以我绝对还不推荐给听众。但这个想法是它会定期扫描你的手机寻找新照片。如果你连上了 Wi-Fi，它会把它们推送到云端。然后我还有一个应用，有一个应用你可以进去。和 Google Photos 非常相似，你可以看到你所有的应用。所以这个应用的工作方式和
the website works is very similar where, you know, you need to see the photo, but the photo is in a, you know, protected URL. You know, it's not, otherwise anyone could just see all of your photos, right? So you kind of need permission to see that one photo. And the way this is done under the hood, which is not my creation, this is just how all the companies do it. And it's built into a lot of these cloud providers, is with something called a signed URL. So if you ever go to Facebook or your Google photos or any of these things where you need to authenticate, you can look at your photos, let's say in your Facebook timeline, and you can go view and tab and you'll have a URL for that
网站的工作方式非常相似，你知道，你需要看到照片，但照片在一个，你知道的，受保护的 URL 中。你知道的，否则任何人都可以看到你所有的照片，对吧？所以你需要权限才能看到那张照片。而在底层实现这一点的方式，这不是我的创造，这只是所有公司都在做的方式，并且内置在许多这些云提供商中，就是使用一种叫做签名 URL（signed URL）的东西。所以如果你去过 Facebook 或你的 Google Photos 或任何这些你需要身份验证的地方，你可以查看你的照片，比方说在你的 Facebook 时间轴上，你可以去查看标签页，你就会拥有该
photo of, let's say, you and your family. And you can actually give that URL to somebody else and even a stranger, and they will see that photo of you and your family, right? So it seems like a security issue. What's actually happening under the hood is they've generated this signed URL that's kind of temporary. And so that URL works for, you know, maybe five hours or one hour or what have you. So effectively, like, you know, it works for your session. And then you'll have to go back and ask Facebook server for a new signed URL to see even the same photo. Now, the challenge is, you know, signing the URL and doing all of that is really expensive, right? Like, and so if you pull up, let's say your Google photos, you know, they might show
照片的 URL，比方说，你和你的家人的照片。你实际上可以把那个 URL 给别人，甚至是陌生人，他们就会看到你和你家人的那张照片，对吧？所以这看起来像是一个安全问题。底层实际发生的事情是，他们生成了这个临时的签名 URL。所以该 URL 的有效期为，你知道，可能是五个小时或一个小时或诸如此类。因此实际上，就像，你知道，它对你的会话有效。然后你得回去向 Facebook 服务器索取一个新的签名 URL，才能看到甚至同一张照片。现在，挑战在于，你知道，对 URL 进行签名并完成所有这些操作代价非常高，对吧？就像，并且如果你打开，比方说你的 Google Photos，你知道，他们可能会在屏幕上直接给你显示
you 20 photos or even 50 photos right off the bat on your screen. All of those are signed URLs. That's 50 signed URLs that Google has to generate. And even when I was testing this by myself on my own Photos app, every time I would hit F5, it would have to generate these 50 signed URLs. And getting the URL signed takes like on the order of maybe tenths of a millisecond or something. So it adds up, right? And so, you know so what you want to do
20 张甚至 50 张照片。所有这些都是签名 URL。那是 Google 必须生成的 50 个签名 URL。甚至当我自己在自己的照片应用上测试这个时，我每次按下 F5，它都必须生成这 50 个签名 URL。而获取签名的 URL 大约需要十分之一毫秒或类似的时间。所以积少成多，对吧？因此，你知道
is you want to sign a URL for somebody and then you want to cache that result. So if they're just hitting F5 or if they're going to different parts of your page where they're seeing the same images, that you're not signing everything again and again and again. You're not signing the same image. And so that's a perfect use case
你想做的是，你想为某人对一个 URL 进行签名，然后你想缓存该结果。因此，如果他们只是按下 F5，或者如果他们访问你页面上看到相同图像的不同部分，你就不用一遍又一遍、没完没了地对一切进行签名。你不用对同一张图片进行签名。所以这是一个完美的用例
for an object caching system. So what I ended up doing was when you ask my Photos app for an image, make sure you're authenticated and all of that. And then it checks this object cache and says, has this person asked me for this image before? And if they have, I just return that signed URL. And if I don't see it in my object cache, then I go and I sign the URL. And so that's kind of one example, but it kind of highlights, you know, it saves you on time. And sometimes, you know, you end up in situations where you really need the cash. But most of the time, it's there to really save you on time and resources. Yeah, I think the other thing, like you mentioned, not just the expense of computing something,
针对对象缓存系统。所以我最终做的是，当你的照片应用请求一张图片时，确保你已经过然后它检查这个对象 cache 并说，这个人以前向我索要过这张图片吗？如果他们索要过，我就直接返回那个签名的 URL。如果我在对象 cache 中没有看到它，那么我就去对 URL 进行签名。所以这算是一个例子，但它突出表明了，它为你节省了时间。有时，你知道，你最终会遇到真正需要 cache 的情况。但大多数时候，它的存在确实是为了帮你节省时间和资源。Yeah，我觉得另一件事，就像你提到的，不仅是计算某东西的开销，
but even retrieving something. So the difference between retrieving something off of even a solid state disk, although it is closing the gap. But if you are talking about, what do they call it? Like read amplification. So sometimes you want to read something. And not only like Jason's mentioning, you have to do something like compute this cryptographic hash of something to sign it, like very expensive. But sometimes you need to pull in five or six or seven or eight different other resources. So one read amplifies
甚至检索某东西也是如此。所以从甚至固态硬盘（solid state disk）检索某东西的区别，尽管它正在缩小差距。但如果你在谈论，他们称之为什麽？比如读放大（read amplification）。所以有时你想读取某些东西。不仅像杰森提到的那样，你必须做一些事情，比如计算某东西的密码学哈希来对它进行签名，非常昂贵；但有时你需要拉入五、六、七或八个不同的其他资源。所以一次读取会放大
out. Now, all of those reads may happen if you're at enough scale in a data center, which are connected by networking switches that cost more than your house. And so they operate all this fiber stuff, like super fancy, low latency, again, but ultimately that data has to live somewhere. And your choices are to live in RAM or to live on disk or tape, I guess, in some case, like a super bad, like long tail case. Yeah. I think the glacier and that stuff still uses some kind of tape, like a robot and tape or something. I don't know. Like that's in one of those horror stories,
出去。现在，如果你在数据中心拥有足够的规模，所有这些读取都可能会发生，数据中心通过比你的房子还贵的网络交换机相连。因此，他们运行所有这些光纤设备，超级棒，低延迟，但最终这些数据必须存储在某个地方。你的选择是存在内存（RAM）中，或者存在磁盘上，或者在某些情况下存在磁带上，我猜，比如超级糟糕的、长尾（long tail）情况。Yeah。我想 Glacier 和那些东西仍然在使用某种磁带，比如机器人加磁带之类的。我不知道。就像那是那些恐怖故事之一，
the guy who gets a ping up on it. Okay. Okay. Sorry. Sorry. Oh no, can't get sidetracked. So if you talk about like cash next to the CPU, you know, RAM speed, and then, you know, hard drive then you know hard drive you're sort of like talking orders of magnitude each one so when you talk about having something in ram versus networking speed you're probably comparable but when you start talking about hard disk speed versus inter computer inter cluster communication not inter cluster communication then it matters a lot right so if you need to do these eight reads you're reading them all out of ram out of computers cluster communication, not intra-cluster communication, then it matters a lot, right?
收到 ping 通知的那家伙。好的。好的。抱歉。抱歉。哦不，不能扯远了。所以如果你谈论接近 CPU 的 cache，你知道，RAM 速度，然后，你知道，硬盘，然后你知道硬盘，你基本上是在谈论每个数量级都差很多。所以当你谈论把一些东西放在 RAM 中与网络速度相比时，你可能具有可比性，但当你开始谈论硬盘速度与计算机间、集群间通信（这里应该是集群内通信，但原文如此）相比时，那就非常重要了，对吧？所以如果你需要做这八次读取，你是在从计算机的 RAM 中读取它们，
So if you need to do these eight reads, you're reading them all out of RAM, out of computers, that can go super fast. Versus if you have to go out to the hard disk to get them, where you get order of magnitude more storage, maybe, or even maybe a lot more, but also order of magnitude slower, you can't keep doing that. And some of those are going to be fetched more often than others. Or if you know, hey, I'm doing this for user, the chance that you get something else from that same user is increased by this first read, then you may want to bring some of that object into a RAM resident storage instead of a disk resident storage. Yeah, that makes sense. Another thing too is, and we talked about this at the very beginning of the show, is your database might be really expensive.
这可以超级快。与如果你必须去硬盘获取它们相比，在硬盘上你可能会获得数量级更多的存储，甚至可能多得多，但也是数量级更慢，你无法一直这样做。其中一些会被比其他更频繁地获取。或者如果你知道，嘿，我正在为用户这样做，通过这次初次读取，你从同一用户那里获得其他内容的几率会增加，那么你可能会想把该对象的一些内容带到驻留 RAM 的存储中，而不是驻留磁盘的存储中。Yeah，这说得通。另一件事也是，我们在节目最开始讨论过，你的数据库可能会非常昂贵。
And so you might want to, you know, if someone's just hitting F5, F5, F5, reloading the page all the time, you don't want that to actually, you know, cause your database costs to go up or cause you to have to buy another database machine and add it to your replica. And so it's often way, way cheaper to spin up an object caching node, an extra node to your object caching system than it is to add a node to your database. Cool. So what are the disadvantages? I mean, we talked a bit about,
因此你可能会希望，如果有人一直在按 F5、F5、F5 重新加载页面，你可不希望这实际上，你知道的，导致你的数据库成本上升，或者导致你不得不购买另一台数据库机器并将其添加到你的副本中。因此，启动一个对象缓存节点，为你的对象缓存系统添加一个额外节点，通常要比向数据库添加节点便宜得多、得多。酷。那么有什么缺点呢？我的意思是，我们讨论了一点，
you can kind of already guess that if you're moving stuff into RAM off of disk or moving it closer, you obviously have less capacity. So if you talk moving stuff into ram off of disk or moving it closer you obviously have less capacity so if you talk about you know having a database of like to to continue jason's example if you have a database of every picture off of every user's phone ever that's not going to fit in as one computer that's going to fit in many many many many computers and so if you talked about having only one computer caching, then, you know,
你大概已经能猜到，如果你把东西从磁盘移到 RAM 中或将它们移得更近，你的容量显然会减少。所以如果你谈论拥有一个数据库，比方说，继续杰森的例子，如果你拥有每个用户手机上每张照片的数据库，那将无法装入一台计算机中，那将需要装入许多、许多、许多、许多计算机中。因此，如果你谈论只拥有一台计算机进行缓存，那么，
obviously, like you can't fit all of that. So you have to be super selective. We talked about a couple of those strategies, right? Time sensitive, you know, aggregating data, deducing data, like that kind of stuff to get it smaller and smaller. But ultimately, to get the speed advantage, you really want to limit how much size you have. And normally that's limited to the memory capacity. Now, RAM sizes have been going up dramatically recently. So like we have gotten some advantage there and with SSDs and stuff, but that's still there. The other thing the object caching tends to do is, I don't want to say garbage or a dump, but like it tends to be just a soup of things. So you are putting all sorts of stuff in
很明显，你无法容纳所有这些。所以你必须超级有选择性。我们讨论过其中的一些策略，对吧？时间敏感的、聚合数据、推导数据，诸如此类的方法使其越来越小。但归根结底，为了获得速度优势，你真的想要限制你有多少大小。通常这受限于内存容量。现在，RAM 容量最近一直在急剧增长。所以就像我们在那方面以及通过 SSD 和其他东西获得了一些优势，但情况依然如此。对象缓存倾向于做的另一件事是，我不想说是垃圾或倾倒场，但就像它往往只是一堆东西的汤。所以你把各种各样的东西放进
the computer to keep it close but your organization normally isn't as clean as it would be in a full like relational database so uh that means that you're not going to have rich queries where you can do filters and scanning all rows and and doing that kind of stuff because it's a disadvantage but it's also it makes sense it's the right tool for the right job. You're already pulling in the results of those complex queries, not doing those queries themselves, or else you just end up back in the same boat you were to start with. The other thing is, if you start storing stuff in memory, you start to have an availability problem, which is if a computer goes down, which even if you have 99.9% reliability, but if you have billions of users,
计算机里以保持它们靠近，但你的组织通常不像在完整的关系数据库中那样干净。所以这意味着你不会有丰富的查询，无法进行过滤和扫描所有行并做那种事情，因为这是一个缺点，但这也是合情合理的，这是针对正确工作的正确工具。你已经拉入了那些复杂查询的结果，而不是自己去执行那些查询，否则你最终只会回到刚开始时的老路子。另一件事是，如果你开始将东西存储在内存中，你就会开始遇到可用性问题，也就是说，如果一台计算机宕机了，即使你拥有 99.9% 的可靠性，但如果你拥有数十亿用户，
you know, the computer where that user's data is stored could go down. And for persistent transactional databases, for things like Jason was mentioning before, like MySQL or Postgres, or, you know, things that you might hear about this, there's very intense thought put into how to make sure that no matter exactly what microsecond you glitch or lose power, that, you know, the database state is sort of consistent and maintained. They don't really do the same thing, because that stuff has overhead, it has cost, and no matter how good you do at it, you're sort of risking some amount of loss. And so most of the time, these object cache systems trade off this simplicity for saying, it might go down if you ask for
你知道，存储该用户数据的计算机可能会宕机。对于持久化事务数据库，对于像杰森之前提到的那些事情，比如 MySQL 或 Postgres，或者你可能听说的东西，人们投入了极其密集的思考，以确保无论你在哪个微秒发生故障或断电，数据库状态都是某种程度上一致且得到维护的。它们并没有真正做同样的事情，因为这些东西有开销，有成本，而且无论你做得多好，你都在冒着某种程度丢失数据的风险。所以在大多数情况下，这些对象缓存系统用这种简单性换取了这样一种说法：它可能会宕机，如果你请求
that key and the key is not present you just got to handle it the client has to know you know what to do or if it goes missing and so you have a lot now some things like we're going to talk about like redis and others do have options for writing out but they're normally much simpler compared to full rd oh relational database management systems. RDBMS. Okay, I almost glitched it when I said it. Yeah, isn't that weird? It's hard to figure out one from the other.
那个键而该键不存在，你就得去处理它，客户端必须知道（你知道的）该做什么，或者如果它丢失了，所以你现在有很多……现在，有些东西像我们接下来要谈论的 Redis 和其他一些工具，确实有写出的选项，但与成熟的 RDBMS（关系数据库管理系统）相比，它们通常要简单得多。RDBMS。好的，我刚才说的时候差点结巴了。Yeah，这不是很奇怪吗？很难把一个和另一个区分开来。
Yeah, I mean, I think that, yeah, you hit it on the head. The persistence in Redis is really for when a machine dies, you want to be able to bring up a replacement machine and move as many of those cache entries as possible so that people don't experience like a hiccup. The purpose of it isn't really for having data that lives forever. And yeah, I mean, you nailed it. I mean, I think another challenge is anytime you have a cache, you run the risk of the cache becoming out of sync with whatever the underlying database is. So imagine you look up what books Patrick's read and you store that in cache. And then while that
Yeah，我的意思是，我想，Yeah，你一语中的。Redis 中的持久化实际上是为了当一台机器死掉时，你能够启动一台替换机器并尽可能多地迁移这些缓存条目，这样人们就不会经历像卡顿一样的情况。它的目的并不是真正为了让数据永远存在。而且，Yeah，你确实说对了。我的意思是，我认为另一个挑战是，每当你拥有一个 cache 时，你都要冒 cache 与底层数据库不同步的风险。所以想象一下，你查询了帕特里克（Patrick）读过什么书并将其存储在 cache 中。然后在这个过程中
cache item is there, Patrick finds another book from Brandon Sorensen that's 2000 pages and starts reading that one. And then when you go back and say, hey, what books has Patrick read now? I just watched the latest episode. You get the old list because it's in cache, right? And so now you have this problem where you either have to delete entries from the cache. So the code that adds books to Patrick's queue would also have to delete any cache entries, you know, involving Patrick. Or you just have inconsistency and you just kind of live with that and you kind of make your whatever's using this system be able to handle that. And so you can actually see this in the real world. Like I know if you've seen this where you end up with weird situations where like sometimes you buy an
缓存项就在那里，帕特里克又找到了布兰登·索伦森写的另一本2000页的书，然后开始读那一本。然后当你回去说，嘿，帕特里克现在读了什么书？我刚刚看了最新一集。你得到了旧的列表因为它在缓存里，对吧？现在你遇到了这个问题：你要么必须从缓存中删除条目。所以向帕特ری克（Patrick）队列中添加书籍的代码也必须删除任何涉及帕特里克的缓存条目，你知道的。或者你只是有不一致性，然后你只能接受这种现实，让使用这个系统的任何东西都能够处理这种情况。你实际上可以在现实世界中看到这一点。就像我知道你是否见过这种情况，最终会出现奇怪的情况，比如有时你购买了一个
item, but the item is not gone from your cart in Amazon. This doesn't happen so much anymore, but I saw this happen a couple of times years and years ago. And that's just because, you know, the different machines at Amazon just have different states. They're not in sync all the time.
商品，但该商品并没有从亚马逊的购物车里消失。这种情况现在不常发生了，但在多年以前，我确实见过好几次。这只是因为，亚马逊的不同机器处于不同的状态。它们并不能一直保持同步。
Yeah, and so that's one of the, it's sort of an extra complexity you have to think about. I went somewhere, you know, talking about that, I did go to some website the other day and it was like, we've complexity you have to think about. I went somewhere, you know, talking about that. I did go to some website the other day and it was like, we've noticed you have two different carts. Would you like us to merge them? And I was like, oh, huh.
是的，所以这是其中之一，这是一种你需要考虑的额外复杂性。我去了某个地方，你知道，说到这个，我前几天去了一个网站，它就像是，我们已经——（这里重复了）——复杂度是需要考虑的。我前几天确实去了一个网站，它就像是，我们发现你有两个不同的购物车。你想让我们把它们合并吗？当时我就想，哦，哈。
Interesting. Okay. And I think it was exactly what you said, which is that like somehow I was on one machine and then I was in another machine and it somehow like reconciled later that like, oh, you've added the same thing in two different places you know i need to resolve this yeah there's um there's a whole thing we should talk about at some point called um i think it's called crdts conflict resolution i think database table i don't remember what the
有趣。好吧。我想这正是你刚才所说的，也就是说，不知怎么的我在一台机器上，然后又在另一台机器上，它后来不知怎么地协调了，就像是，哦，你在两个不同的地方添加了相同的东西，你知道我需要解决这个问题。是的，有一个……有一个完整的话题我们应该在某个时候讨论，叫做……我想它叫做CRDT，冲突解决（Conflict Resolution），我记得数据库表……我不记得那个t是什么了，但
t is but oh interesting it's a way to it's a way to have different machines that are writing to the same source and the conflicts are resolved. I want to say automatically. I mean, a better way of saying it is the conflicts are resolved through a policy. And that policy sometimes does what you want. Sometimes it doesn't. But at least it's like automatic. And so, for example, if you use Google Docs and you have a shared doc and you and someone else are typing at the same time, under the hood, it's actually a CRDT. But yeah, if you're writing something in Redis or Memcache, then you have to handle all the conflicts manually. And maybe you have a CRDT on top of it that does it for you.
哦，真有趣。这是一种方法，它是一种让写入相同源的不同机器的冲突得到解决的方法。我想说是自动的。我的意思是，更好的说法是冲突通过策略得到解决。而该策略有时会做你想做的事。有时不会。但至少它就像是自动的。因此，例如，如果你使用Google Docs，并且你有一个共享文档，你和其他人同时在打字，在底层，它实际上就是一个CRDT。但是，如果你在Redis或Memcache中写入内容，那么你必须手动处理所有冲突。也许你在它之上有一个CRDT为你完成这件事。
But someone has to decide what to do when those things are out of sync i would say there's another topic for us as well talking about eventual consistency and transactional and guaranteed and the trade-offs that makes i think that's been a big space of exploration recently yeah totally yeah maybe we should do uh so you know we we actually when we were looking up this show we found we did a database show but it was episode 34 which is uh probably like a decade ago so um so what we're doing is we're going to probably dive really deep into databases and yeah we should definitely add that to the list you know like acid compliance and all the consistency you know guarantees and and the trade-offs there so So under the hood, almost all of these object caching systems are key value stores, right?
但是当这些东西不同步时，必须由某人来决定该做什么。我想说，这也是我们的另一个话题，谈论最终一致性和事务性与有保证性以及由此带来的权衡，我认为这最近是一个很大的探索领域。是的，完全是这样。也许我们应该做个……所以，你知道，我们实际上在查找这个节目时发现，我们做过一个关于数据库的节目，但那是第34期，大概是十年前的事了……所以，我们要做的就是，可能会深入探讨数据库，是的，我们绝对应该把它加入列表中，比如ACID合规性和所有一致性保证以及其中的权衡取舍。所以在底层，几乎所有这些对象缓存系统都是键值存储，对吧？
And so, you know, you could use, you know, Berkeley DB or Amazon's Dynamo or any key value store, LevelDB, any key value store would, could double as an object caching system, you know, under the hood. I mean, Redis might be using LevelDB under the hood. I don't even object caching system you know under the hood i mean redis might be using level db under the hood i don't even know but you know it's effectively a key value store but it just gives you a lot of nice things on top of that so you know one of the one of the things it
所以，你知道，你可以使用……你知道，伯克利DB（Berkeley DB）或亚马逊的Dynamo，或者任何键值存储，LevelDB，任何键值存储都可以在底层兼作对象缓存系统。我的意思是，Redis可能在底层使用的是LevelDB。我甚至都不知道……对象缓存系统，你知道的，在底层，我的意思是Redis可能在底层使用LevelDB，我甚至不知道，但它实际上就是一个键值存储，但它只是在此基础之上为你提供了很多很好的功能。所以，你知道，其中一个
does for you is it supports multi-get or multi-set so you know in the example i gave you know person goes to jason gauchi photos which it doesn't have a name yet but but uh you know, in the example I gave, you know, a person goes to Jason Gauci Photos, which doesn't have a name yet, but they go to this photos thing and they see, you know, 20 photos at once. And so that means, you know, if it's their first time, I need to set 20 signed URLs in one shot. And if it's not their first time, I want to kind of get 20 or get as many as there are. And so, you know, in most of these cases, you're not just looking at one cache entry, you know, at a time. And so they have really nice APIs and also under the hood, really nice ways of getting multiple things in parallel and they make that super fast. Another thing that the object caching does is it lets you set expert expiry times so as we talked about we have this cache sync issue and so um you know one nice way of
它为你做的事情是它支持multi-get（多键获取）或multi-set（多键设置），所以在我和你分享的例子中，一个人去了Jason Gauci Photos，虽然它还没有一个名字，但……但是，你知道，在我给出的例子中，一个人访问Jason Gauci Photos（虽然它还没有名字，但他们访问了这个照片的东西），他们看到，你知道，一次有20张照片。这意味着，你知道，如果这是他们第一次来，我需要一次性设置20个带签名的URL。如果这不是他们的第一次，我想获取20个或者获取尽可能多的URL。所以，你知道，在大多数情况下，你不仅仅是一次只查看一个缓存条目。因此，它们有非常好的API，并且在底层也有非常好的并行获取多个对象的方法，它们使之变得超级快。对象缓存的另一件事是它允许你设置过期时间（expiry times），正如我们所讨论的，我们存在这个缓存同步问题，所以……你知道，一种好方法
of dealing with that or so one sort of hands-free way of dealing with that is just to set an expert expiry time on the cache they look this cache is relevant for maybe an hour. And after the hour, you assume the person logged off Facebook. Use the Facebook example. It doesn't need that picture anymore. Or after an hour, you say, well, there's a good chance something's out of sync. And so I'll just throw it out. And if the person, if I'm regenerating this every hour, it's so much better than regenerating every request, right? Maybe you even set it to a minute and that's still a huge improvement over not having a cache.
处理这个问题的方法，或者说一种免手动处理这个问题的方法，就是简单地在缓存上设置一个过期时间，他们看，这个缓存可能在一个小时内是相关的。一个小时后，你假设这个人已经退出了Facebook。以Facebook为例。不再需要那张图片了。或者一个小时后，你会说，好吧，有些东西不同步的可能性很大。所以我干脆把它扔掉。如果这个人，如果我每小时重新生成一次，这比每个请求都重新生成要好得多，对吧？也许你甚至把它设置为一分钟，这仍然比没有缓存有巨大的改进。
So it's good support for, you know, and they will handle when that minute is up, you know, destroying that item for you. The last bit on how this works is, you know, we can't talk about this without understanding hashing. Now, we did a whole show on hashing, so we won't rehash it here. But, you know, you have to, as Patrick said, maybe you're making this complicated query to a database to get, you know, all the books that this group of people have read. And now you need to take that result and cache it which means you need to way to index it by a key so you have to take whatever logic went into getting this data the first time and you have to convert it into some unique identifier so that next time if you make the same query you get the same identifier and so the best way to do that
因此，它对……而且它们会处理当那一分钟到期时为你销毁该项目。关于这是如何工作的最后一点是，你知道，如果不了解哈希（hashing），我们就无法谈论这个。现在，我们做过一个关于哈希的完整节目，所以我们不会在这里重新讨论它。但是，你知道，正如帕特里克所说，你必须这样做，也许你正在对数据库进行复杂的查询，以获取这群人阅读过的所有书籍。现在你需要获取该结果并将其缓存，这意味着你需要一种方法通过键（key）对其进行索引，所以你必须采取获取此数据的任何逻辑并将其转换为某种唯一标识符，以便下一次如果你进行相同的查询，你就会得到相同的标识符，所以最好的方法
is with hashing. So you could imagine you could hash the raw SQL query. You could hash a URL in my case that I want to sign. But there's, I think in my case, I actually hashed the user ID, you know, concatenated with the URL because I think it mattered which person you were. But yeah, you kind of, you know, hashing is a huge part of being able to do object caching. So I think the most common one, or at least the first one I heard of, although I think that these first two are probably tied, I'll probably get flack for saying one over the other. Anyways, the first one I heard of was Redis.
是用哈希。所以你可以想象，你可以对原始SQL查询进行哈希处理。你可以对我想要签名的URL进行哈希处理。但是，我认为在我的情况中，我实际上是将用户ID与URL连接起来进行哈希处理，因为我认为具体是哪个人很重要。但是，是的，你知道，哈希是能够进行对象缓存的巨大组成部分。所以我想最常见的，或者至少是我听说的第一个（虽然我认为前两个可能不相上下，如果我说一个比另一个好，我可能会挨骂）。无论如何，我听说的第一个是Redis。
And when Redis first started out, it was sort of interesting, because when it was described to me, it was like, yeah, this is like, you know, like a hash map that you just like run on your computer. Just like one computer, like you just stand it up and it just runs a hash map. People can put what they want there and get what they want from it. And it has like a few extra features, but like super said, when we even first covered database, I hadn't the experience of large scale systems and all of these complexities we just described. So I was like, that just seems like a crappier version of a relational database. I too could just write a network server that serves up my hash map. Of course, it doubles in the details with adding other data structures and any sort of backend
当Redis刚开始的时候，这有点有趣，因为当它被描述给我时，就像是，是的，这就像是一个……就像你在电脑上运行的一个哈希映射（hash map）。就像一台计算机，就像你把它架起来，它只运行一个哈希映射。人们可以把他们想要的东西放在那里，并从中得到他们想要的。它有一些额外的功能，但是正如超级……当我们在第一次介绍数据库时，我没有大规模系统的经验，也没有我们刚才描述的所有这些复杂性。所以我想，这看起来就像是一个更糟糕的关系型数据库版本。我也完全可以编写一个提供哈希映射的网络服务器。当然，细节决定成败，比如添加其他数据结构以及任何后端
or having it split between computers and segmentations and partitions. Okay, anyways. So Redis for sure enjoys a lot of popularity here. Adding other features like PubSub. So if something is modified, you could subscribe to it and sort of know and handle it.
或者将其拆分到多台计算机、分段和分区中。好吧，无论如何。所以Redis在这里绝对享有很高的热度。添加了诸如PubSub（发布/订阅）之类的其他功能。因此，如果有什么被修改了，你可以订阅它，并能知晓和处理它。
Memcached is another big one that's super, super popular. In fact, I don't know. Jason, do you know which one might be if we had to make a call, which one's more popular? Memcached is much older. Oh, okay. Then I just heard about them wrong. Yeah, but I think the velocity of Redis
Memcached是另一个非常非常受欢迎的大型缓存。事实上，我不知道。Jason，你知道如果我们必须做出选择，哪个更受欢迎吗？Memcached要老得多。哦，好吧。那我刚才就听错了。是的，但我认为Redis的发展速度
is way, way higher. The adoption of Redis, the rate of adoption of Redis is way higher. So I don't know which one's more popular. But yeah, you hit the nail on the head. Those are the two big juggernauts. One thing you mentioned, which I forgot to talk about earlier, is this is multi-node. So you can have a Redis cluster of hundreds of machines, and they're all kind of working together. And when you ask for a key or you store a key, you don't have to think about which machine to put it on or anything like that.
要快得多。Redis的采用率，Redis的普及速度要快得多。所以我不知道哪个更受欢迎。但是，是的，你一针见血。这两个是巨无霸。你提到的一件事是我之前忘记谈论的，那就是这是多节点的（multi-node）。所以你可以拥有一个由数百台机器组成的Redis集群，它们都在某种程度上协同工作。当你请求一个键或存储一个键时，你不必考虑把它放在哪台机器上或类似的事情。
And as opposed to like a MySQL cluster where it's mostly done through replication, the Res cluster is truly distributed, where like a lot of the keys only exist in one of the nodes. It's not like a full replication or anything like that so there's a lot of complexity getting that right so what like an extra 10 lines of code yeah exactly it's just it's a little bit it's like one line of code more than writing a that extension that scans swagger there's a cloud oh a full fully distributed highly available swagger scanner yeah other you know key value store systems uh you know can work here so you know amazon has dynamo google i'm sure has something google cloud has some kind of key value store is it is it called like big big big? No, there's BigQuery,
与MySQL集群主要通过复制完成不同，Res集群是真正的分布式，其中很多键只存在于其中一个节点中。它不像完全复制或诸如此类的东西，所以要把这一点做好需要有很多复杂性。所以，就像多写10行代码一样？是的， exatamente，它只是一点点……这就像比编写那个扫描Swagger的扩展多写了一行代码。哦，云……一个完全分布式的、高可用的Swagger扫描器。是的，其他（你知道的）键值存储系统……你知道，也可以在这里工作。所以，你知道，亚马逊有Dynamo，谷歌确信也有某种东西，谷歌云有某种键值存储。是不是叫什么Big Big Big？不，有BigQuery，
which is a SQL thing. Yeah, I don't know what the calling here would be. Like you say, I mean, I think it's very common. It's called Datastore. There's a whole like also line of things.
这是一个SQL东西。是的，我不知道这里该叫什么。就像你说的，我的意思是，我认为这很常见。它叫做Datastore。还有一整套类似的东西。
What we've been talking about is sort of like per user, but there's also huge amounts of work for like content delivery networks is that the right acronym cdns and caching and that's a whole we've not really talked about any of it but if you sort of take a lot of their problems we've just described if we talk about like how do you push large volumes like youtube if you want to watch a youtube video all over the world you don't want
我们一直在谈论的是类似于每个用户（per user）的，但内容分发网络（CDN）也有大量的工作要做，这是正确的缩写吗，CDNs和缓存，这是一个我们根本没有真正谈论过的整体。但如果你把我们刚刚描述的许多问题拿过来，如果我们谈论像YouTube这样的大流量推送，如果你想在全世界范围内观看YouTube视频，你不会希望
that being served from like a single computer's redis database i mean that's not what happens obviously but like that doesn't work right so like you have cdns and like entire distribution and peering agreements and caching data and like all of these things are just something for outside i don't even have a ton of experience they're actually interesting guests i'm sure we yeah i was just thinking that we should have someone who really knows cdns to come on the show? I mean, there's been several companies go public with huge revenues in this CDN space and sort of bringing data to closer to the user, closer to the edge, which we've overused before. But anyways, yeah, I mean, we haven't talked about those. These aren't really solutions for that. But in my mind, like, I'm not sure I understand exactly how the two interplay.
从一台计算机的Redis数据库提供服务。我的意思是，显然不是这样的，但这行不通，对吧？所以你有CDN和整个分销和对等协议（peering agreements）以及缓存数据，所有这些东西都超出了我的范围，我甚至没有丰富的经验。它们实际上是有趣的嘉宾，我确信我们……是的，我刚才就在想，我们应该请一个真正懂CDN的人来节目？我的意思是，在这个CDN领域有几家公司上市并获得了巨额收入，并将数据带得更接近用户，更接近边缘（edge），我们之前过度使用了这个词。但无论如何，是的，我的意思是，我们没有谈论过这些。这些真的不是针对那类问题的解决方案。但在我看来，我不太确定我完全理解这两者是如何相互作用的。
Yeah. I mean, the thing about CDN, I mean, we talked to, we talked to that gentleman about, about doing edge computing, Jackson. We talked to Jackson about edge computing, and we talked a little bit about this, but, but yeah, I mean, CDNs have to deal with this challenge of, you know, I have this image, but it's on, you know, data centers and edge servers all over the world, which, where should I actually get it from for you? Right. And so that, yeah, that, I mean, we should dedicate a whole show to that. It'd be super fascinating. Oh, another one to mention is along the similar lines is when you're on mobile, you know, you often want to cache things on your phone so that you don't have to go to the internet
是的。我的意思是，关于CDN，我的意思是，我们跟……我们和那位绅士谈过关于做边缘计算（edge computing）的事，Jackson。我们和Jackson谈过边缘计算，我们稍微谈了谈这个，但是，是的，我的意思是，CDN必须应对这样的挑战：我有这个图像，但它分布在世界各地的 数据中心和边缘服务器上，我实际上应该从哪里为你获取它呢？对吧？所以，是的，我的意思是，我们应该为之专门做一期节目。那会非常迷人。哦，另一个要提的类似的事情是，当你使用手机时，你知道，你通常希望在手机上缓存东西，这样你就不用去访问互联网了
especially if you're not on wi-fi and so you know that is kind of a whole different level a whole different caching layer because there might be times where like you literally can't get the underlying key so for example you, someone has configured their app to not use any Wi-Fi or not run on, or sorry, to only run on Wi-Fi, not fetch anything on metered data. Like imagine a podcast app. And so they only want the podcast that they've downloaded. So if you don't want to write all of that from scratch, you're saying, oh, have you downloaded it? If so, play it, etc. There's a whole bunch of tooling around that as well, like object caching systems for your phone.
特别是如果你没有连接Wi-Fi，所以你知道，那是一种完全不同的级别，一个完全不同的缓存层，因为有时你可能真的无法获取到底层的键，例如，某人将其应用程序配置为不使用任何Wi-Fi或不运行，或者抱歉，只在Wi-Fi上运行，不在计量数据（metered data）上抓取任何东西。想象一下播客应用程序。所以他们只想要他们下载的播客。因此，如果你不想从头编写所有这些代码，你就会说，哦，下载了吗？如果是，播放它，等等。围绕这一点也有很多工具，比如手机的对象缓存系统。
The one I'm most familiar with is the Firestore, which is from Firebase. And so I believe that works on Android and iOS. But there's a whole bunch of these systems for dealing with metered connections and for caching things like that. I want to go back. I have not for fear, but I want to go back i have not for fear but i want
我最熟悉的一个是Firestore，它来自Firebase。所以我想它在Android和iOS上都可以运行。但是有一大堆这样的系统用于处理计量连接和缓存类似的东西。我想回去。我不是出于害怕，而是想回去
to go back to uh some of our early episodes and listen and we were talking about this if you haven't heard it yet in the the holiday episode or christmas episode but like growth as engineers and like decisions we made a long time ago and how they've impacted us but just thinking through like how i used to view coming out of college databases and then like the richness with like, which you and I are talking about. And I'm by no means an expert. I actually do more embedded work. So databases are far from my day-to-day experience, but just like how much more like that, it's just like one of those things like looking back and you think,
回到我们早期的一些节目去听听，我们在谈论这个，如果你还没听过的话，在假期特辑或圣诞特辑里，关于作为工程师的成长，以及我们很久以前做出的决定以及它们如何影响我们，但只是思考……我刚大学毕业时是如何看待数据库的，以及你和我谈论时的那种丰富性。我绝不是专家。我实际上做更多嵌入式工作，所以数据库离我的日常经验很远，但只是……回首过去，你会觉得
you know a lot about something and it turns out you basically know nothing. Yeah. I mean, that's fascinating. I mean, you know a lot about something and it turns out you basically know nothing. Yeah, I mean, that's fascinating. I mean, the way you described Redis when you first heard about it is exactly what I thought too. And so, you know, when episode 34 went out, our description of Redis probably does not do it justice at all.
你对某事了解很多，结果发现你基本上一无所知。是的。我的意思是，这太迷人了。我的意思是，你对某事了解很多，结果发现你基本上一无所知。是的，我的意思是，这太迷人了。我的意思是，你第一次听说Redis时对其的描述完全就是我想的。所以，当第34集播出时，我们对Redis的描述可能根本没有做到实事求是。
It'd be fascinating to listen to that. I bet we'd be, yeah, we would be face palming the whole time. Maybe we should do that as like a charity thing. If people donate enough to charity, we'll suffer through listening to all that. We'll do a Twitch stream of like live listening to ourselves. granted things like you have all these keys each one expires at a different time you have to handle that you have 10 different nodes each one has a tenth of the data yeah and so it's just it's it's it was yeah we both had like really superficial knowledge of the stuff i never took actually they they offer database classes at university but i never took them i was always taking like all the
听那个一定很有趣。我敢打赌我们会……是的，我们会全程扶额。也许我们应该把这当作一个慈善活动。如果人们向慈善机构捐款足够多，我们将痛苦地听完所有这些。我们将做一个Twitch直播，直播收听我们自己的声音……诚然，有些事情比如你有所有这些键，每个键都在不同的时间过期，你必须处理它，你有10个不同的节点，每个节点都有十分之一的数据。是的，所以它只是……它确实是……是的，我们俩对这些东西都只有非常肤浅的知识。我从未上过……实际上，他们在大学里开设数据库课程，但我从未选修过。我总是选修所有的
algebra linear algebra stuff so so so yeah i mean and now in hindsight you know at least if you want to build something on web it's it's uh it's so important to know how how all these things work at a like more deep level yeah i was listening to you're talking about like hidden complexity i was listening to podcasts i don't even remember which one it was and it was talking about someone who did not even like true high frequency trading but just like not low frequency trading on stock markets and was talking about you know like yeah if you want to just describe it simplistically like you get the not the price quotes but the order book like who has outstanding orders and what is the order flow and then you just like reconcile it over time and you watch it he's like except like you get misquotes constantly
代数、线性代数之类的东西。所以……所以……是的，我的意思是，现在回想起来，你知道，至少如果你想在Web上构建一些东西，了解所有这些东西是如何在更深层次上运作的是如此重要……是的，我刚才在听你谈论隐藏的复杂性，我当时在听一个播客，我甚至不记得是哪一个了，它谈论的是一个甚至不是做真正的高频交易，而只是做股票市场上的非低频交易的人，并且谈论的是，你知道，是的，如果你想用简单的话来描述它，你得到的不是报价，而是订单簿（order book），谁有未完成的订单以及订单流是什么，然后你只是随着时间推移去对账（reconcile），你看着它，他说，除了……你会不断地收到错误的报价
and you have to decide like what's true and what's not true so like it's this weird thing that you know for me i like go to the internet and like say what is the price of tesla today um and you get some number right but in reality that number under the hood there's all these outstanding bids for selling and buying and they update like many many many times a second and then there's also like all this data error where you know like you occasionally get misquotes or things get broken or not quite right and you have to like also filter all of that out so like maybe the naive thing you could build in a few hundred lines of code in a few days or whatever, depending on your skill and familiarity. But then there's just this huge long tail of like complexity that you have to work your way down just to like improve it.
你必须决定什么是真的，什么是假的。所以这是一件奇怪的事情，你知道，对我来说，我上互联网，然后说特斯拉今天的价格是多少，你会得到一个数字，对吧？但实际上，在底层，那个数字有所有这些未完成的买卖报价，它们每秒更新很多很多很多次。然后还有所有这些数据错误，你知道，你会偶尔收到错误的报价，或者事情坏了，或者不太对劲，你还得把所有这些都过滤掉。所以，也许你可以在几天内用几百行代码构建一个幼稚的东西，无论如何，取决于你的技能和熟悉程度。但随后就会有大量长尾的复杂性，你必须一路摸索着解决，仅仅为了改进它。
Yeah, I mean, dude, that, oh my gosh, I mean, we could spend hours talking about that. But that blows my mind. Like when you say I want to buy something like a share of Tesla, I guess what happens, I'm going to sound dumb here, but I guess what happens is if you say, I want to buy a share of Tesla, you know, like, um, Charles Schwab or whatever system you're using pre-populates a price. And my guess is that price is just set high enough that there's like a pretty good guarantee that you're going to buy. I mean, I know you can be fancy and say like, I want this price, you know, and if I don't get it, then I'm not interested or whatever. A limit order, I think it's called or whatever. But the interesting thing to me is what number
是的，我的意思是，老兄，那个……哦天哪，我的意思是，我们可以花几个小时谈论这个。但这太让我震撼了。就像当你说我想买点东西，比如一股特斯拉，我想发生了什么，我在这里听起来可能很蠢，但我想发生的事情是，如果你说，我想买一股特斯拉，你知道，比如，嘉信理财（Charles Schwab）或你使用的任何系统都会预先填充一个价格。我猜那个价格被设置得足够高，以至于有一个相当好的保证你会买。我的意思是，我知道你可以花哨一点说，我想要这个价格，你知道，如果我没拿到，那我就不感兴趣了，或者诸如此类。限价订单（limit order），我想是这么叫的或者别的什么。但对我有意思的是什么数字
they put there for you. You know, it's like, it's like, how did they pick that number? They're just showing you the last transaction price. the last price a successful transaction was done at oh so well but there has to be some amount of signal processing there right because there could be some anomalous transaction and that would throw everybody off right well but that's that's oh okay well we can't this is this is fire yeah we're gonna stay forever it might be buried here so i'm not the right person. We should find a guest. I'm sure if one of you out there is in the financial industry
他们为你放在那里的。你知道，这就像是，他们是怎么挑选那个数字的？他们只是向你展示最后一笔交易的价格。成功完成上一笔交易的价格是……哦，好吧，但那里必须有一些信号处理，对吧？因为可能会有一些异常交易，那会把所有人搞砸，对吧？好吧，但那是……哦，好吧，我们不能……这太火爆了，我们会永远留在这里。可能被埋在这里，所以我不是合适的人选。我们应该找个嘉宾。我确信如果你们当中有人在金融行业
and wants to talk a bit about the... I don't think we've ever really covered that in depth here, but that's its own thing. I mean, tons of software engineers work this field every day. Get in contact with us, and we'll look for someone on our side as well. But I don't want to get into... I also don't know. That's not my expertise, but I think maybe a bit more than you,
并且想谈谈……我想我们从来没有在这里深入探讨过这一点，但那是它自己的东西。我的意思是，每天都有大量的软件工程师从事这个领域。与我们联系，我们也会在我们这边找人。但我不想深入探讨……我也不知道。那不是我的专长，但我想可能比你稍微多一点，
but that'll be a whole raffle and this will go on for another hour. Yeah. Let's just put the call out there. If you are a engineer or product manager or anybody at a company that does some cool software, solves some really interesting problems, you know, reach out to us. I mean, we had the gentleman Abhay from Anduril who reached out to us and it was an amazing show. It's one of my favorite episodes. So, you know, if you do something cool out there,
但这将是一场大混战，这还将持续一个小时。好吧。让我们发出号召。如果你是工程师、产品经理或任何一家开发炫酷软件、解决非常有趣问题的公司的员工，（你知道的）联系我们。我的意思是，我们有来自Anduril的Abhay先生联系了我们，那是一场精彩的节目。这是我最喜欢的剧集之一。所以，你知道，如果你在那里做一些很酷的事情，
you know, reach out to us and, you know, feel comfortable talking to a lot of people. Definitely reach, I mean, I just want to put it out there. I mean, I wish I could sugarcoat it, but, you know, you are talking to a lot of people, definitely reach out. I mean, I just want to put it out there. I mean, I wish I could sugarcoat it, but you are talking to a lot of people. It does make some folks nervous, but no, I think there's a lot of people out there who really would love to listen
你知道，联系我们，并且愿意和很多人交谈。绝对要联系，我的意思是，我只是想把它说出来。我的意思是，我希望我能把话说得委婉一点，但你知道，你在和很多人交谈，绝对要联系。我的意思是，我只是想把它说出来。我的意思是，我希望我能把话说得委婉一点，但你在和很多人交谈。这确实会让一些人感到紧张，但是，不，我认为有很多人真的很想听听
and hear from your experience. And so if you do stuff in financial, that would be fascinating. If you do other stuff, definitely reach out. Programmingthrowdown at gmail.com. Wow, that was a great segue into finishing off the episode. Well, thanks, everyone, for listening. Yeah, whether you want to be on the show or you just enjoy listening,
并倾听你的经验。所以如果你在金融领域做事情，那将是非常迷人的。如果你做其他事情，请务必联系。Programmingthrowdown at gmail.com。哇，这是一个结束节目的绝佳过渡。好吧，谢谢大家的收听。是的，无论你想上节目还是只是喜欢收听，
thank you so much for hearing us out. And have a great 2022. See you all next time. Music by Eric Barndaller. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you
非常感谢你们听我们唠叨。祝大家2022年过得愉快。我们下次再见。音乐由Eric Barndaller提供。Programming Throwdown根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0协议发布。您可以自由共享、复制、分发、传输作品，以 remix、改编作品，但您
must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
必须署名我和帕特里克，并以相同方式共享。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。